about five years ago a woman named Nikki
Petry accidentally bounced a check for
$28 in ninety three cents and judge
milas Hale who goes by the nickname of
butch uh is involved in what some are
calling a so-called debtors prison in
Arkansas sentenced her to jail last
month even though she had paid hundreds
of dollars in court fines she had been
arrested in connection with the case at
least seven times she's now unemployed
and taking care of her father she was
never asked whether she had the
financial means to afford the thousands
of dollars of fees that the court wanted
to collect from her in connection with
the single bounced check and because she
was unable to pay those thousands of
dollars in fines the alternative is 35
days in jail this is practically
speaking a debtors prison now it's not
literally that right because really what
it is is she was assigned finds by a
court and then because she didn't pay
the fines as an alternative she was
allowed to and that's insane language
she was allowed to instead of paying the
fine spent 35 days in jail but this is
effectively a debtors prison isn't it
essentially yeah I I don't believe that
banks or education funding you know
loans etc they shouldn't be predatory
like this I've I feel like this is one
of the major changes that needs to
happen in our country and I know certain
countries don't allow this these is a
socialistic 50 years ago what I put it
be put in jail myself for even having
this idea definitely but I think it's
something that we need to spread to the
masses now in the interest of uh clarity
there are also countries that are way
harsher in terms of their punishment for
small financial crimes most people in
the US would not ever point to those
countries and say we should be more like
them I really don't like it when we say
okay let's compare one aspect of what we
do to what France does let's compare
another aspect of what we do to what
Saudi Arabia does who's saying the
country should be more like Saudi Arabia
so I hate defenses of what goes on in
the US based on what goes on in
in some of the most extreme countries
that sort of an aside though I tend to
agree with you I mean this is a way in
which we already see people are in many
ways indentured to the financial and
corporate test system of the United
States and when you even can end up
staying spending 35 days in jail because
of what originally started as a $28 in
93 sent bounced check something has gone
horribly wrong and I know at every level
it can be justified well if he bounced
the check this happens and if you go to
court you have to pay back the fees and
if you can't pay back the fees then
you're given the option of spending time
in jail but the the trajectory is $28 93
sent bounced check to $35 in jail and
that's bonkers yeah yet if you steal
billions oh no big deal oh we're
actually gonna help you out after the
fact and keep ya company in business
that's oh yeah make sense we're sorry
that you had to steal billions because
we didn't help you out enough to begin
with so we're actually gonna give you
even more money now so that you don't
have to steal in the future we're sorry
you had to steal I'm sorry is the
government that you had to steal will
help you out now yet this is the to
justice systems that we've been talking
about if there's ever a clearer picture
of that its corporate bailouts compared
to 35 days in jail after not being able
to pay thousands and finds all stemming
from a $28 and 93 sent bounced check uh
that's it for the bonus show today we'll
talk to you tomorrow